mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour la nuit dernière a marqué un
retour à la violence en irlande 7 morts
peut être plus et une vingtaine de
blessés par des coups de feu tirés au
hasard dans belfast au vietnam en
revanche il semble que le contrôle du
cessez-le-feu s'organisent pour devenir
suffisamment efficace on parle aussi de
la libération dans le courant de la
semaine prochaine des premiers
prisonniers américains au nord vietnam
en france vive réaction du conseil de
l'ordre des médecins ou manifeste de 330
médecins français favorables à la
liberté de l'avortement mais tout de
suite pour ouvrir ce journal une
exclusivité monsieur georges gaillez se
porte bien
dix jours après avoir subi une
transplantation cardiaque son état
clinique est bon et le traitement est
exceptionnellement bien supporté
déclarait-il hier soir la direction de
l'hôpital foch à suresnes
une caméra a été admise ce matin à
l'hôpital dit sartre ou les vous étiez
là aussi vous avez pu voir l'opérer du
coeur à travers des vitres
comment l'avez-vous trouvé aubin en
excellente santé
j'ai eu l'impression de voir un opéré de
l'appendicite par exemple il était
couché il avait un transistor à sa
droite un livre parfaite santé
j'étais étonné d'ailleurs nous allons
voir alors ces images qui ont pu être
filmés ce matin évidemment loperhet du
coeur se trouve dans une chambre stérile
le voici dans une chambre une unité
stérile c'est à dire une chambre où il
ne doit exister aucun virus qui puisse
mettre la vie de monsieur qu'allié en
danger voici pourquoi nous avons dans
notre corps un système de défense qui a
pour but normalement de combattre et de
rejeter les virus mais qui rejette aussi
tout corps étranger le coeur greffé est
un corps étrange donc on a neutralisé ce
système d'auto défense pour permettre au
corps de monsieur kaliev de s'habituer à
ce nouveau coeur soit gentil
je
mëme cri pas oui assayas est retiré oui
avec l'allemagne et l'argentine
ghislain gentiment mais ils sont pas
comment ils ont l'habitude comment
trouvez-vous votre pari moi je trouve
très bien très bien
vous êtes optimiste surtout on attaque
le 11e jeu et à partir du 12e jour une
yann soi disant pour ne pas dire de
bêtise soit disant ça doit aller mieux
le gros coup est passé son moral
l'extrême très très bon
oui nous n'avons pas entendu monsieur
caillé ce cas il n'y avait pas de micros
dans le chemin non il est totalement
isolé on le peut le voir on peut
éventuellement lui parler à travers la
vitre mais enfin c'est discret quand
même mais à ce soir vous nous
présenterait dans notre journal 19h45
une séquence plus complète je crois même
vous avez assisté au déjeuner oui nous
avons assisté au déjeuner nous avons
interviewé le professeur et qu'il mais
qui cherchent un kilo il est permis
d'imaginer aussi qu'un homme a suivi
avec émotion ses images que nous venons
de voir maintenant c'est emmanuel
vitryat bien sûr qu'ils marseille et le
actuellement le doyen français d opérer
du coeur
la législation française sur
l'avortement est cette fois au pied du
mur le manifeste signé par 330 médecins
et publiées hier par le nouvel
observateur et le monde est un événement
suffisamment important pour que le
ministère de la justice et publié un
communiqué dès hier soir
je vous rappelle que ces médecins
affirment avoir sinon pratiquer du moins
favorisés l'avortement
ils réclament la liberté totale de
l'interruption de grossesse
pour le ministère de la justice qui
rappelle les propos de monsieur plevent
devant l'assemblée nationale au mois
d'octobre
le gouvernement est parfaitement
conscient de ce que la législation doit
évoluer aussi bien en raison des progrès
de la science médicale que pour d'autres
facteurs multiples et vaines avait
rappelé aussi que les juridictions
pénales applique d'ailleurs la
législation avec un grand sens de
l'humain réservant leur rigueur aux
avorteurs professionnels toutefois il
n'est pas possible pour autant avait il
dit aussi de légiférer sans peser toutes
les conséquences morales ou sociale des
lois sur un problème qui touche si
profondément la conscience de chacun
voici deux témoignages celui de l'un des
3 130 médecins et puis la réaction du
président du conseil de l'ordre le
professeur lortat jacob
en ce qui concerne le médecin
signataires nous l'avons filmé deux
profils il n'a pas voulu en effet être
reconnu non pas en raison de ses
déclarations sur l'avortement
mais pour ne pas être en infraction avec
le conseil de l'ordre sur le plan de la
publicité écoutons le docteur vous êtes
signataires de ce manifeste ne craignait
pas en prenant cette position aussi
catégorique à l'égard des avortements
d'enfreindre la loi et
encourir des sanctions or nous sommes
tout à fait conscients de reprendre la
loi par la position que nous prenons
ceci dit la position que nous prenons et
que nous avons mûrement réfléchie ce
n'est pas par rapport à la loi qui n'a
plus aucun rapport à la situation
actuelle en france mais par rapport aux
femmes qui nous consultent tous les
jours dans nos cabinets et qui nous pose
le problème de l'avortement
le problème pour nous c'est de savoir si
ces femmes voir avorter dans des
conditions de clandestinité souvent
dramatiques pour réel qui peuvent
entraîner la mort ou la mutilation
définitive
sans parler des problèmes psychologiques
elles peuvent rencontrer ou si ces
femmes vont avorté interrompre la
grossesse dans de bonnes conditions
techniques de bonnes conditions
médicales qui existe à l'heure actuelle
qui sont utilisés dans tous les pays
étrangers je pense que c'est un
manifeste qui est fait en faveur d'un
mouvement qui se dessine depuis quelques
mois pour libéraliser l'avortement avoir
le nom de personnes et les gens qui ont
signé tusa rapidement hier cette
pétition cette magnifique se manifeste
et ils sont des heures tellement
différent les des ophtalmologistes et 6
kg à des dermatologistes ne pense pas
que tous ces commerçants des avortements
c'est donc des opinions qu'ils émettent
pour soutenir une cause bien là on ne
fait pas de procès d'opinion et l'on n'a
rien pas intervenir paris matière si
parmi eux n'a que peu d avortement
réellement fragnes enquête on verra ne
sait pas alors d'affaires cette enquête
car matière d'avortement c'est toujours
la justice qu intervient en premier et
l'ordre n'intervient que sur plainte du
procureur ultérieurement si la justice
estime que l' interview ni à
interviendra l'ordre verra ensuite ce
qu'il a fait à noter que l'on s'occupe
de plus en plus actuellement du problème
de base qui est celui de la
contraception depuis quelques jours en
effet un important sondage a été lancée
en france auprès de tous les médecins et
devront dire s'ils ont constaté ou non
des accidents auprès des fans qui
utilisent la pilule
la politique c'est demain que les
candidats députés pourront commencer à
s'inscrire les candidatures seront
reçues jusqu'au 11 février à 24 heures
et c'est alors que s'ouvrira
officiellement la campagne électorale
deux mouvements politiques doivent
présenter aujourd'hui leur candidat le
front national
un mouvement de droite dont le leader
est monsieur jean marie le pen et le
front des jeunes progressistes qui sont
des gaullistes de l'opposition et dont
le secrétaire politique et monsieur
dominique gallet
à noter aussi que le conseil national de
l'alliance républicaine pour le progrès
se tient aujourd'hui présidée par
monsieur jean louis tixier vignancour
parmi les dernières déclarations
politiques retenons la mise au point de
monsieur gaston defferre nous ferons at
il dit hier soir au puy nous ferons tout
ce qui sera en notre pouvoir
lorsqu au premier tour le candidat
communiste sera en tête pour que les
voix socialistes se reportent
intégralement sur lui au deuxième tour
le nouveau la terreur en irlande du nord
des coups de feu tirés au hasard par les
occupants d'une voiture ont fait sept
morts au moins et 20 blessées la nuit
dernière à belfast déjà tout l'après
midi d'hier la ville avait vécu des
heures angoissantes un coup de téléphone
avait annoncé qu'une bombe se trouvait
dans un camion citerne chargé de
quelques 18 mille litres d'essence il
s'y trouvait en effet il a fallu
plusieurs heures
un artificier pour la désamorcer tandis
que tout le quartier était évacué une
nouvelle fois disent les observateurs
protestants et catholiques sont prêts à
un affrontement sanglant
on peut en revanche espérer que le
cessez-le-feu pourra être effectivement
respectées au vietnam ce matin avait
lieu à saigon la première réunion de la
commission de contrôle et de la
commission militaire mixte
cette réunion s'est déroulée dans un bon
climat a déclaré l'ambassadeur du canada
monsieur gobine qui préside
provisoirement la commission de contrôle
et monsieur gobine indiqué d'autre part
que les premiers prisonniers de guerre
américains pourraient être libérés dans
le courant de la semaine par le nord
vietnam environ 600 soldats américains
sont prisonniers du nord et pour ceux
qui sont au sud il y à la guerre bien
sûr mais le vietnam a aussi d'autres
charmes témoins
ces images de nos envoyés spéciaux
commentée par thierry thibault
alors que les dernières unités
américaines quittent le site vietnam
pour regagner les états unis les
derniers mariage mixte américano
vietnamiens se célèbre à saigon dans la
joie d'une paix retrouvée
des milliers de gi's ont découvert au
vietnam les douceurs de la vie asiatique
et le charme de ses habitantes
l'occupation américaine au japon avait
vu des dizaines de milliers de mariage
ni l'intervention américaine au vietnam
en a vu autant le problème des america's
bien si l'on peut employer ce mot va se
poser dans les années à venir ainsi que
leur insertion dans la société
américaine
c'est à la mode vietnamienne et dans la
religion bouddhiste que le capitaine
moore a épousé fleurs de printemps
l'autel des ancêtres étaient surchargés
de présents après les changes de fruits
entre les mariés la noce passa à table
cochon de lait pâté impérial canard
laqué et d'autres plaintes
la famille de la mariée était au grand
complet car au vietnam on a encore le
sens de la famille de la tribu pour être
conviés
du côté du marié deux compagnons d'armes
et sa mère
vous êtes américains ou marié au vietnam
où il épouse une vieille famille n
pourquoi pourquoi est ce que j'aime bien
dire combien de temps vous êtes au
vietnam
je suis et 20 mois depuis 18 mois et
j'ai commencé mon baptême tories fond
mais vous allez emmener votre part en
amérique comme en salle et emmenez votre
femme en amérique et bien sûr sur cette
photo de famille dans une ville qui a
retrouvé la paix on ne risque plus de
déplorer
nous allons avoir tout de suite en
direct des images de ce qui les images
qui nous arrive d'autriche et lien
français qui semblent en bonne place
pour le slalom spécial c'est jean-michel
odeur un habile wayne jean noël augert
que nous allons voir apparaître dans
quelques instants sur l'écran le voici
jean noël augert alors que la deuxième
manche du slalom géant de 50 tonnes a
été le départ était donné il ya quelques
instants à peine alors après la victoire
de russie en descente hier on espère
aujourd'hui voir lescure français aux
premières places
le slalom est une discipline où sont nos
scores sont beaucoup plus à l'aise pour
le moment gustavo anthony a réalisé le
meilleur temps thot général 106 secondes
88 centièmes au cours de la première
manche
jean noël augert vous voyez ce qui est
ici avait réalisé le troisième temps à
60 2 centièmes de seconde de tenue donc
le résultat de chant noël augert dans
cette deuxième manche va conditionner
directement le classement final
jean noël augert à 62 centièmes de
seconde de retard sur tony nous vous le
disions tout à l'heure et gustavo tony a
réalisé 53 secondes 21 au cours de la
deuxième manche
et pour jean noël augert 54 secondes 24
donc jean noël augert ne pourra dominer
gustavo tony du savon tony qui est l'un
des meilleurs spécialistes
de slalom spécial et de slalom géant qui
remporte ainsi sa deuxième de
vraisemblablement sa deuxième victoire
en coupe du monde cette année puisqu'il
avait déjà gagné adelboden et bien le
hasard a bien fait les choses puisque
nous avons donc pu assister en direct à
cette descente de jean noël augert quad
aux transports aujourd'hui il ya des
rencontres importantes en football et
puis vous venez de connaître l'équipe de
france de rugby
c'est cela il y à il ya quelques
instants après nous avons eu
communication de l'équipe de france de
rugby il faut dire que nous sommes rendu
compte hier que les joueurs français
n'était pas les barbarians il faudra
élaborer un jeu d'attaqué beaucoup plus
brillant pour espérer surprendre alb
l'accent test-match samedi prochain au
parc des princes les sélectionneurs ont
d'ailleurs tenu compte de ce principe en
constituant tout à l'heure une équipe de
france qui a quand même très belle
allure vous le voyez peu de changement
c'était à prévoir par rapport à l'équipe
de france ecosse sinon en trois quarts
ou disparaissent les ailiers luxe et
bourgarel au profit de qu'anthony et
vers tran qu'anthony a donc glissé de
l'ariège allèles et c'est le bagnèrais
accueillir jean michel accueillir qui
apparaît à l'arrière il avait fortement
impressionné les sélectionneurs à tarbes
mercredi dernier contre les all-blacks
jo maso on le voit n'a pas été retenu
pour le match de samedi
quant à walter spanghero il est encore
une nouvelle fois bien sûr le capitaine
de l'équipe de france et puis deux
changements enfin en première ligne avec
la rentrée du talonneur bénésis et celle
du pilier basque
hazard est bien un très rapidement
seulement maintenant les rencontres
importantes de football cet après-midi
et bien en football la course poursuite
va continuer entre le leader nice et ses
suivants immédiats c'est à dire nantes
nîmes marseille et saint-etienne nice va
jouer cet après midi à mettre le club de
combine nantes et nîmes sont également
en déplacement à rennes et ajaccio puis
en basket quelques résultats d'hier soir
très intéressant
berck s'est imposé à nilvange 116 à 80
mais vichy a perdu lui un match très
important à nancy 82 à 80 alors que
villeurbanne ni pour deux points
également
eh bien ils étaient plus heureux il
remportait une victoire à nice 89 à 90
ans une déception l'automobile avec eux
françois cevert tu
oui car françois cevert posséder une
avance confortable aux 24 heures de
daytona il avait douze tours d'avancé
sur la porsche carrera de données iuf
olmert
or la matra simca qui s'acheminait
semble-t-il vers une victoire assez
confortable après dix heures de cours
cela et bien été victime d'un incident
mécanique important le moteur explosé ce
ne fut pas d'ailleurs le seul un
accident au cours de cette course
puisqu'ils et une porsche qui a brûlé
également françois cevert était alors un
kilomètre 500 de son stand
il a tenté de pousser sa voiture et puis
après il a il a renoncé malheureusement
matra simca n'avait engagé qu'une seule
voiture dans cette compétition des 24
heures de daytona sur l'un des circuits
qui est incontestablement l'un des plus
difficiles bien je vous remercie notre
journal est maintenant terminée nous
vous souhaitons un bon après midi rendez
vous donc à 19h45